prodi segreti che diciamo assoluto dio
perché quando vivevo nostra casa notizie
attuale avevo l'abitudine di utilizzare
i cetrioli di tre denti niente
trastullarmi per capitato anche di
lontane dalle altre praticamente che
potevano spesa perché ciccioli c o
quando hai dei coinquilini
ognuno ha un tot di cetrioli a mensola
c'era il fruttivendolo che la vedeva il
solito tale signora quindi è uno di quei
casi in cui le dimensioni della verdura
contano che una grande allegoria della
vita lo sciacquava quella sono ripianato
cucinava ciao ragazzi bentornati a una
nuova puntata di vita buttata il tema
della puntata di oggi è quello che non
ho mai detto un po di giorni fa vi ho
chiesto su facebook di farmi sapere
quali fossero quelle cose che vi siete
sempre tenuti dentro e che non avete mai
detto a nessuno mi avete mandato dei
messaggi vocali
ho pensato pronta così importante di
invitare all'interno degli studios di
casa mia una persona che non si sa
tenere un cecio che è sempre lì come una
sorta di paris è un signore i ragni un
ragno tessitore ex a tutto che non si sa
cosa gli dicono i suoi uccellini anche
se la maggior parte delle volte non si
sa cosa gli dica il suo uccello mio
fratello gabriele balarm organici
borgoni socia tutti madre santissima
a tutti voglio dire a questo punto di
partire e ascoltare che cosa ci è
arrivato va bene ma lei una riflessione
forte che richiede però non so per quale
motivo delle volte quando mi annoio
riesco a mangiarmi le unghie dei piedi e
vengono i toni e quindi sia in un asilo
l'abilità paziente scusa a cisaria
superiore è vero e ci si potrebbe
balzare a mangiare mangiare come
potrebbe fare c'è dovrebbe girare le
dita il piano debba arrivare con
saprebbe porsi in posizione con un
baciamano kalambaka piede a ti ringrazio
per questa confessione è comunque uno
snack organico a km zero è come il 6
luci più amano ha detto che c'è una
repulsione quindi in realtà è come
quando da piccolo ti mangi le verdure
non ti vanno matti fanno bene gabriele è
calzante se ad esempio che il piede al
armor goonies io ogni tanto di come sono
dei capi cisti di lavinio all'art
senti perché non fai a ci può stare è
una roba che c'è un regista americano
qui abbiamo lavorato dire no che
soffiava il naso e poi come se fossero
pancake e proprio ma tanti a tutta la
serie è che gli veniva automatico e poi
e poi ti venivo a dare la mano magari
non posso sapere nell'orecchio solo chi
è
[Risate]
[Musica]
auguri ma è sposato ma ci sono 40 anni
niente rehn non ha detto niente quindi
resta così auguri di fare un test per
natale cioè che i dvd allegato sapevo
l'avete progetti a tre anni sia al terzo
fine rapporto che questa è una verità
comune penso fra il 96 per cento delle
donne per chi maschi dai pensano di
essere sempre stati dei grandi ramo
numerici e tu hai questa condizione
certo la donna brava e quella che te lo
fa credere bene e quindi ti lascia in
questa condizione palato eri tu hai a
casa felice racconti agli amici e non è
vero niente
questa versione mediocre ragazze mi fate
sapere qua sotto già perché lo fate è
una questione di imbarazzo tipo almeno
non chiedo spiegazioni e non devo tanto
poi c'è l'altro e quindi poi combinati
tu hai raggiunto una sorta di
sufficienza per rifare direzione dio che
la finestra in casa come retto bene
non abbastanza pesante da raccontare una
logica verona e all'estero per la casa
per una settimana
in quel periodo ero nipoti la dipendente
[Musica]
dopo i primi tre giorni capirete usato
uno spazzino e le chiedo di mettere come
mente non lo sono portieri e chi no tra
32 e katie per alimenti insomma tu che
parli tanto mentre loro parlano ai
adesso c'è silenzio e non vedono esiste
la tua voce perché la mia vita mamme
vengono sulmona non rus b per la mia
pianta daniele parla nutrita e non mi fa
sentire le cose e poi arriva il momento
di parlare i tool di mani così capitolo
a c'è scritto avuto sì la crisi
clorofilliana cosa mi consola tema di
pancia per saltare correre in matematica
in cui non mi sono preparata nei
desiderata l'ospedale è una materia che
l'ospedale io ero pietrificata non
potevo ormai vere mamma papà sta
fingendo sicura che fosse un libro fatto
di investigarono la 16 te beh io ero
talmente spaventata mi fece operare e
quindi adesso la cicatrice veratro
indici tematici di vite ma i medici non
se ne rendono conto che non ha un
appendicite sai che non nord
ma soprattutto si muovono semplicemente
no ma evidentemente da quella che era la
sua reazione hanno detto per forza
appendici sogno che quelle cose che è
stata un'escalation che ormai non
potersi tornare indietro è l'omicidio
ormai berbatov oggi stavo cento delle
metafore c'entrano niente che stiamo per
dire ti casca la cosa oddio il caso è
svenuto norma ammazza poi che nasconde
il corpo ormai e tele di colpo 66 un
assassino e lo stai sporzionate
ripartito magari che ne so chi era dato
cinque vite sempre la verità sono amori
la qualità paga sempre bravo sono molto
contento di averti qui con me cose da
dire no ma intanto non si capirebbe meno
confesserei una cosa che capire se sono
gianluigi vieni qui ragazzi in palletta
della contentezza non esiste questo nome
non sapete di cosa stiamo parlando di
fare niente e ho passato un imparabile
numero che per ore a causa di questi una
chicca piccolino mi divertivo a
dipingere tra le varie cose che faceva e
diceva che quando io attendevo i miei
quadri insieme a gian luigi facevamo il
balletto della contentezza sola canzone
di una cosa che non è mai esistita come
è bello fare questa festa se ci sono
altri ci sono le cose che dicevo i miei
cugini che loro attaccavano i quadri
facevano questo balletto uno di questi
si chiama la gloria di gerusalemme due
case in mezzo alla terra per arabella
davo creata bella cena e la cosa bella è
che tutti i nostri cugini nostra
famiglia quelli pure presenti li hanno
creduto a lui se no ma certo era un
naturale abbiamo cominciato a crederci
una crede veramente
scusate ragazzi questo è un momento
troppo ragazzi stiamo girando il video
con gabriele sulle confessioni e lui
appena detto una cosa il coraggio di
ripeterla
no tanto se non ha appena detto una
verità terribile 22 anni dopo è uscita
allo scoperto la verità la verità sono
così contento che vorrei fare il
balletto della contentezza tu credevi al
balletto l'avvocato ed era il mio modo
per prenderli in giro della loro pittura
diciamo della verità volevo dipingere io
meloni p dio forse sulla gloria di
gerusalemme
geniale e inutile che dopo 22 anni
cerchiate di insabbiare le cose non oso
immaginare cosa abbiate fatto a quel
poveraccio per costringerlo a tanto n
dello spezzino per la nfl pubblicato
tutti gli uomini devono morire ma che se
dice palermo rulli
chi attacca tenta così di mia
fidanzatina infatti costa 6
nell'innocenza ha poi era piccola voglio
di giochino più di te la stai vedendo
come una cosa sempre maniaca cento
finisce c'era è molto innocente magari
ma ancora più secondo me gesù non si
offeso balarm album raccontarlo mai ma
nesima di intenzione lontane cucina una
sera mi contatta impagliata devo
raggiungere qui tiro ma ndo
preoccupatissima a siena raccapricciante
nido in avanti è praticamente una volta
realtà porta di casa il ragazzo cui
uscirà al 90 con la bottiglia
lei era come se carrello è un passato
mezz'ora per cercare vittorie da bravi
ragazzi ma cosa più importante è che qui
stiamo avendo a che fare con una ragazza
che nonostante abbia fatto artù con la
spada nella roccia farà pacchi da che
era poi non l'ha detto a nessuno a detta
sua se non a noi
ogni migliori amici me avrei dovuto dire
come pratica quindi si sono messe un
piede per chi a far truppe due parti
come fanno uno scippo è che un sacco di
persone l'anno all'ospedale in pronto
soccorso
ma pensa che a volte alcune persone ci
rimangono incassate per nove mesi dove
ragazzi siamo arrivati alla fine di
questo video come sempre vi ringrazio
dei messaggi che mi mandate ringrazio
anche gabriele per essersi prestato a
fare questa cosa qui fatemi sapere qua
sotto ma non dovete farlo del forza con
i tre giornali perché non può sentire
questo modo da non lo fate sapere queste
cose segreti veniva se vi chiedono è se
volete prendere i prossimi video
iscrivetevi in questo canale attiva
della campanella
noi come sempre ci vediamo la prossima
settimana sempre di giovedì alle 14 ciao
sono un [ __ ]
nome russo il balletto della contentezza
com'è bello fare questa festa cara lalla